At this point, all Chris McKinney has is a positive attitude, because, frankly, the facts do not look too promising. What am I talking about? I'm talking about man against nature, one boy's story. Every weekend, 17-year-old Chris McKinney wades out into knee-deep water, alone, with a shovel, and a wooden contraption, and nylon sandbags. And he proceeds to fill 20 sandbags, 50 pounds each, one at a time.
在这一点上，克里斯·麦金尼（Chris McKinney）所拥有的仅仅是一种积极的态度，因为坦白讲，事实看起来并不那么乐观。我在说什么呢？我在说人与自然的抗争，一个男孩的故事。每个周末，17岁的克里斯·麦金尼都会独自一人，带着一把铁锹、一个木制装置和尼龙沙袋，涉水走进齐膝深的水中。他开始一个个地装沙袋，每个重达50磅，总共要装20个。
I take it out of the sandbag holder, and I tie the top to the sandbag. And I carry it over to the sandbag wall and stack it where it needs to be stacked. And that's about it. I mean there's not a whole lot to it.
我把它从沙袋支架上取下来，把袋口系好。然后把它扛到沙袋墙边，堆放在需要堆放的地方。就这样了。我是说，这其实没什么复杂的。
Doing this for a full day, Chris can add about five feet to his sandbag wall. It's not much. He's putting his wall on a thin strip of beach, a strip that's barely wide enough to stand on in Mason Neck State Park in Virginia. The shore here is eroding at the rate of two feet a year, so fast that the ground has collapsed underneath the trees at the edge of the beach. For half a mile, these huge, 60 and 70 foot trees have toppled over into the water, one after another, because the ground holding them upright is gone. It's complete devastation. And there, in the middle of it, is Chris's tiny sandbag wall.
这样干上一整天，克里斯能给他的沙袋墙增加大约五英尺。这不算多。他把墙建在弗吉尼亚州梅森颈州立公园（Mason Neck State Park）一片狭窄的沙滩上，那里的宽度几乎容不下一个人站立。这里的海岸线每年以两英尺的速度侵蚀，速度快到沙滩边缘的树木下方土地已经塌陷。在半英里的范围内，这些巨大、60到70英尺高的树木一棵接一棵倒进水里，因为支撑它们直立的土地已经消失了。这完全是毁灭性的。而在这一切的中心，就是克里斯那小小的沙袋墙。
Do you have a name for this wall?
你给这道墙起名字了吗？
Yeah, it's the sandbag wall.
是的，就叫“沙袋墙”。
He's been at it for a month and a half. And it's just a fraction of what it needs to be. He's trying to protect this one small stretch of beach where there's a path, this pathway that's about to be eroded out of existence. His wall is just 30 feet long. And that's probably-- I don't know-- a third or maybe a fourth of what it needs to be. And Chris has a deadline.
他已经干了一个半月了。但这只是所需工程的一小部分。他试图保护这一小片有小径的沙滩，这条小径即将被侵蚀得不复存在。他的墙只有30英尺长。而那可能——我不知道——只是所需长度的三分之一甚至四分之一。而且克里斯有一个最后期限。
That's December 19. That's my 18th birthday.
那是12月19日。那是我的18岁生日。
Chris is doing this project as one of the requirements to become an Eagle Scout. His fear, by the time he finishes the sandbag wall, he will be too old to be a scout. Once you turn 18, you're out of scouting.
克里斯做这个项目是为了达到成为鹰级童军的要求之一。他担心，等他完成沙袋墙时，他就因为太老而无法成为童军了。一旦满18岁，你就得退出童军。
You must be getting frustrated at how long it takes?
你一定因为进度太慢而感到沮丧吧？
Well, slightly. Usually, I'm frustrated when the friends I've known for a while, they'll tell me they'll help out, but they don't always show up. But I understand. There are things I'd rather do on Saturday than do an Eagle project. But it is my Eagle project. And no one else is going come out there.
嗯，稍微有点。通常，当那些我认识很久的朋友答应帮忙却没露面时，我会感到沮丧。但我理解。周六有很多事情比做鹰级项目更吸引人。但这毕竟是我的鹰级项目。而且不会有别人来这里做。
Have you ever read those stories about people who just get a big mission in their head, and they're just going to make it happen no matter what?
你有没有读过那些关于人们脑子里有了个伟大的使命，无论如何都要实现它的故事？
Right. Well yeah, Christopher Columbus was one of them. So yeah, I've heard a lot of those stories. I'm pretty sure I'm one of those people. I can do this.
对。嗯，没错，克里斯托弗·哥伦布就是其中之一。所以，是的，我听过很多这样的故事。我很确定我就是那种人。我能做到。
Do you feel like this is one of those stories?
你觉得这像其中一个故事吗？
Yeah. Well, not as big as those. But whatever I set my mind to, I'm definitely capable of doing. And I know I can do it. I'm confident.
是的。嗯，虽然没有那些那么宏大。但无论我下定决心做什么，我绝对有能力做到。我知道我能行。我很有信心。
Chris said this to me over and over in different ways. And I have to say as an outsider, unless he gets his entire Boy Scout troop in there helping out, it is really hard to see how he is going to finish this wall. But when you're against nature, trying to do something so much bigger than you are, what else can you say?
克里斯一遍又一遍地用不同的方式对我这么说。我必须说，作为一个局外人，除非他能让整个童军小队都来帮忙，否则真的很难看出他怎么能完成这道墙。但当你与大自然作对，试图做一件远超你能力范围的事情时，你还能说什么呢？
So positive attitude is 90% of it, right there. And I like to think I'm pretty positive about this. So 90% of it is already done. The worst is already behind me. And it only gets better from here. Anything else?
所以积极的态度占了其中的90%，就是这样。我愿意认为我对这件事很积极。所以90%的工作已经完成了。最糟糕的情况已经过去了。从现在开始只会越来越好。还有别的事吗？
For somebody who is so confident, you sure are saying it a lot.
对于一个如此自信的人来说，你确实一直在重复这句话。
Well, I always have to tell myself these things, because sometimes I get unsure. And if I ever let any doubt in my head, it'll just multiply. It doesn't die. It multiplies. And to keep that out of my head, I just have to keep on saying the right thing. Just, oh yeah, you're almost done.
嗯，我总是得这样告诉自己，因为有时我会感到不确定。如果我让任何怀疑进入脑海，它就会不断滋生。它不会消失，只会增加。为了不让它进入我的脑海，我只能不停地说正确的话。就是，哦，是的，你快完成了。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, people competing with nature in contests they might not win. Act One, Running After Antelope. We have the latest installment in Scott Carrier's 12-year quest to chase and catch an animal that runs 40 miles an hour by foot. Act Two, children derail a network television show, the true story of how 200 eight-year-olds wreaked havoc in one of the most controlled settings known to man, a late-night network talk show, in this case, Conan O'Brien's. Stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和公共广播国际台的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天在我们的节目中，讲述的是人们在可能输掉的比赛中与大自然竞争的故事。第一幕，“追逐羚羊”。我们将播出斯科特·卡里尔（Scott Carrier）12年追逐梦想的最新篇章——徒步追赶并捕捉一种时速40英里的动物。第二幕，“儿童使电视网节目脱轨”，讲述了200名八岁儿童如何在人类所知的最受控的环境之一——深夜电视网脱口秀，也就是柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）的节目中制造混乱的真实故事。请继续收听。
Act One, Running After Antelope. Humans' dominion over nature is so complete that most of us never get into a competition with nature where we can not come out on top. Well, Scott Carrier has this story, a story about somebody trying to do something that seems, on its face, impossible. And about why he'd want to, and about how he tried to keep a positive attitude. It's also partly a story about how humans became humans, about the moment that we became bipedal, that is the moment that we stood upright on two feet and separated from the apes. For 12 years, Scott wanted to prove that we stood on two feet, as a species, to run.
第一幕，“追逐羚羊”。人类对自然的统治是如此彻底，以至于我们大多数人从来没有陷入过一种无法获胜的自然竞争中。那么，斯科特·卡里尔有这样一个故事，一个关于某人试图做一件表面上看起来不可能的事情的故事。关于他为什么想要这样做，以及他如何努力保持积极的态度。这也部分是一个关于人类如何成为人类的故事，关于我们变得双足行走的那一刻，也就是我们挺直腰杆用双脚站立并与猿类分离的那一刻。12年来，斯科特想要证明，作为物种，我们用双脚站立是为了奔跑。
1963. The hunt begins at dawn, my brother pulling me out of bed onto the floor. "C'mon, c'mon." I'm tying my shoes. And he's out the door. Outside, the fog is lifting off the grass. I'm looking for my brother. But I can't even see the car in the driveway. Then he comes running from the backyard. I jump and run and catch up with him across the street in the Mander's backyard. And he says, "Some animals sleep in the daytime and go out at night to eat. If we hurry, we can catch them before they go back in the ground."
1963年。狩猎在黎明时分开始，我哥哥把我从床上拉到地板上。“快点，快点。”我在系鞋带。他已经冲出了门。外面，薄雾从草地上升起。我在找我哥哥。但我连车道上的车都看不见。然后他从后院跑过来。我跳起来跑过去，在马德尔（Mander）家的后院追上了他。他说：“有些动物白天睡觉，晚上出来吃东西。如果我们快点，能在它们钻回地里之前抓住它们。”
I believe him. I have no idea how he knows these things, but he does. He goes out and runs through our neighbors' yards and catches wild animals with his bare hands, mainly lizards, turtles and snakes. He wraps them in his shirt and brings them back to the cages in our basement so he can study them for science. He's seven years old. I am six.
我信他。我不知道他是怎么知道这些的，但他就是知道。他跑遍邻居的院子，用双手捕捉野生动物，主要是蜥蜴、乌龟和蛇。他把它们裹在衬衫里带回地下室的笼子里，以便为科学研究观察它们。他七岁。我六岁。
I'm running along behind him. And when I lose him in the fog, I follow the tracks he leaves in the dew on the grass. I catch up to him. And he's down on his hands and knees, crawling through the juniper bushes in front of the Gooch's house. He says, "There is a garter snake in there. I saw it. It went right in front of me." He's crawling around, breaking branches, and I hear the front door open.
我在他身后跑着。当我在薄雾中失去他的踪迹时，我循着他在草地的露水中留下的脚印走。我追上了他。他正跪在地上，爬过古奇（Gooch）家门前的刺柏丛。他说：“里面有一条吊带蛇。我看到了。它就在我面前钻进去了。”他在周围爬行，折断树枝，我听见前门开了。
And there's our neighbor, Daisy Gooch, in her bathrobe. She looks 10 feet tall and 900 hundred years old, and says, "What's going on out here?" I say, "There's a snake in your bush." She says, "There's no snake in my bush. You boys get out of here now." And she starts for us with her broom.
我们的邻居黛西·古奇（Daisy Gooch）穿着睡袍出现了。她看起来有10英尺高，900岁了，她说：“这儿在闹什么？”我说：“你的灌木丛里有条蛇。”她说：“我的灌木丛里没有蛇。你们这些男孩现在就滚出去。”她拿着扫帚向我们冲来。
We take off running. We don't need to run that far. It's not like she's going to come after us. But we keep running anyway. We jump the fence at Finn Gerholdt's house. And we're on the golf course, heading toward the gully. My brother says, "I think I figured out a way to run and not get tired. It's all in how you breathe. Yesterday, I ran over to the gully and down to the river and back, and I didn't get out of breath. I think I can run as far as I want." "Like the Indians," I say. "Yeah, like the Indians." We have everything we need. The wilderness is unfolding in front of us.
我们跑开了。我们不需要跑那么远。她又不是真的会追我们。但我们还是不停地跑。我们跳过芬恩·格霍尔特（Finn Gerholdt）家的栅栏。我们到了高尔夫球场，朝沟壑跑去。我哥哥说：“我想出了一种奔跑而不累的方法。关键在于呼吸。昨天，我跑过沟壑，到河边再跑回来，我一点也没喘气。我想我能跑多远就跑多远。”“像印第安人那样，”我说。“对，像印第安人那样。”我们拥有需要的一切。荒野在我们面前展开。
1982. My brother is a master's student in the biology department at the University of Utah. And he works in Dr. Dennis Bramble's laboratory in the basement of the building. He has asked me to help him with an experiment. He shows me the inside of the lab's freezer, full of dead animals, road kill he's picked up or animals he's had to kill himself for science. He is studying to be a vertebrate morphologist.
1982年。我哥哥是犹他大学生物系的一名硕士研究生。他在该楼地下室的丹尼斯·布拉姆布尔（Dennis Bramble）博士的实验室工作。他让我帮他做一个实验。他向我展示了实验室冷冻柜里塞满了死去的动物，有他捡到的路杀动物，也有他为了科学研究不得不亲自杀死的动物。他正在学习成为一名脊椎形态学家。
For the experiment, we walk over to the football stadium, which is empty except for us. He fastens a Styrofoam cup over my mouth. The cup has a wireless microphone inside of it. He straps another microphone to my right ankle. Then he says, "OK, run around the track. Run a mile." I run four laps, and it's not easy. I'm out of shape from smoking too much. I tell my brother, "I'm sorry." And he says, "That's OK. That's why I asked you. We need data from bad runners."
为了这个实验，我们走到足球场，除了我们之外那里空无一人。他往我嘴上扣了一个聚苯乙烯泡沫杯。杯子里装有一个无线麦克风。他把另一个麦克风绑在我的右脚踝上。然后他说：“好了，围着跑道跑。跑一英里。”我跑了四圈，这可不容易。我因为吸烟太多，身体状况很差。我告诉哥哥：“抱歉。”他说：“没关系。这就是我找你的原因。我们需要糟糕跑步者的数据。”
I ask him what he's doing. And he says, "We, Dennis and I, are studying how animals breathe when they run. When quadrupeds gallop-- animals like horses and dogs and cats-- they have to inhale every time they stretch out in their stride and then exhale when they come forward with their back legs. It's because of the way their diaphragm is connected to their backbone. But in humans, our diaphragms don't have that connection. And we can breathe in whatever pattern we want to or need to."
我问他在做什么。他说：“丹尼斯和我在研究动物跑步时是如何呼吸的。当四足动物奔跑时——像马、狗和猫——它们必须在每次伸展步伐时吸气，然后在后腿向前迈进时呼气。这是因为它们的横膈膜与脊骨相连。但在人类身上，我们的横膈膜没有那种连接。我们可以按照任何我们想要或需要的模式呼吸。”
"So why is that important or interesting?" I say. And he says, "Humans are really good endurance runners. I know I can outrun a dog. And I think I can maybe outrun a horse on a hot day. So for some reason, we've evolved this way. And maybe the way we breathe might have something to do with it. Why can we run farther than just about any other animal?"
“那这为什么重要或有趣呢？”我问。他说：“人类是非常出色的耐力跑者。我知道我能跑赢狗。而且我觉得在炎热的天气里，我甚至可能跑赢马。所以出于某种原因，我们进化成了这样。也许我们的呼吸方式与此有关。为什么我们能跑得比几乎任何其他动物都远？”
"Well, how do you explain it?" I ask. And he says, "I think bipedalism might be an adaptation for endurance running, and that maybe our earliest ancestors could run down big game without using any weapons at all. I found ethnographic accounts of primitive people who are able to do it. The Tarahumara in Mexico could run down deer. The Aborigines in Australia could run down kangaroo. The Goshutes and Navajo here in the West are said to have been able to run down pronghorn antelope.
“那你怎么解释？”我问。他说：“我认为双足行走可能是对耐力奔跑的一种适应，也许我们最早的祖先可以在不使用任何武器的情况下追捕大型猎物。我找到了一些原始民族能够做到这一点的民族志记录。墨西哥的塔拉乌马拉人（Tarahumara）可以追捕鹿。澳大利亚的原住民可以追捕袋鼠。西部的戈舒特人（Goshutes）和纳瓦霍人（Navajo）据说曾经能够追捕叉角羚。”
"I tried it last summer with some antelope in Wyoming, just for an hour or so. And they basically ditched me. But I want to try it again. I could use some help, if you want to do it." I say, "You want to try to run down an antelope?" And he says, "I don't know if we can, but I think we should try it."
“我去年夏天在怀俄明州尝试过追捕一些羚羊，也就一个小时左右。它们基本上甩掉了我。但我还想再试一次。如果你想加入，我需要帮手。”我说：“你想尝试追捕羚羊？”他说：“我不知道我们能不能做到，但我认为我们应该试一试。”
1984. In the summer, my brother and I go to Wyoming to try to run down an antelope. The idea is not to run faster than the antelope-- only cheetahs can run faster than pronghorn antelope-- but to run longer and farther in the heat of the day. My brother thinks it'll take about two hours, and then the antelope will overheat and collapse. We drive off the interstate and down a dirt road for a few miles. And it's a wide and open high desert of sagebrush, dry as a bone, mountains in every direction. And there are antelope everywhere, in pairs, in clusters, in families, by themselves.
1984年。夏天，我和哥哥去怀俄明州尝试追捕羚羊。这个想法不是要跑得比羚羊快——只有猎豹能跑得比叉角羚快——而是在酷热的白天跑得更久、更远。我哥哥认为这大概需要两个小时，然后羚羊会因为过热而崩溃。我们驶离洲际公路，沿着一条土路开了几英里。这是一片广阔开放的高原荒漠，长满了鼠尾草，干燥如骨，四面环山。到处都是羚羊，成双成对的、成群结队的、成家庭的，或是单独的。
We stop the car and start running after three, a buck and two does. They run very quickly but for short distances, and then stop and stare at us until we catch up. And then they take off again. Sometimes, they run a quarter of a mile, sometimes a half mile. My brother is a much better runner than I am. And I'm way behind, looking out for sagebrush and rattlesnakes and cactus, tired already, but laughing. It's a lot of fun, a lot more fun than running down the street or even up in the mountains. I keep my brother in sight, and although I sometimes lose the antelope, I can tell they're running in a broad arc, clockwise. And so I aim to cut them off. And it works. I catch up with them, even ahead of my brother. And they stand there and let me get within 50 yards of them.
我们停下车，开始追赶三只羚羊，一只公的和两只母的。它们跑得很快但距离很短，然后停下来盯着我们看，直到我们追上。然后它们又跑开了。有时它们跑四分之一英里，有时半英里。我哥哥比我跑得好得多。我远远地落在后面，还要留心鼠尾草、响尾蛇和仙人掌，虽然已经很累了，但我在笑。这非常有趣，比在大街上跑步甚至在山上跑步有趣得多。我盯着我哥哥，虽然有时会跟丢羚羊，但我能看出它们正沿着宽阔的弧线顺时针奔跑。于是我打算截住它们。奏效了。我追上了它们，甚至超过了我哥哥。它们站在那里，让我靠近到50码以内。
Antelope have big black guys, eyes the size you'd see in a horse. And they look at me like they know exactly what I'm proposing, and they're not in the least bit worried. They look at me, and I stare back, and this goes on for maybe a couple of minutes. I don't know. I can't say, because something happens. It's like being hypnotized or like being abducted by aliens who take me to another planet, where they do things to me I can't remember before they bring me back to the exact same place, and only a few seconds have elapsed.
羚羊有巨大的黑色眼睛，和马的眼睛一样大。它们看着我就好像知道我打算干什么，而且一点也不担心。它们看着我，我也盯着它们，这持续了大约几分钟。我不知道。我说不好，因为发生了什么事。就像被催眠了，或者像被外星人绑架了，带到了另一个星球，在那里它们对我做了一些我记不清的事情，然后在我回到原处时，只过了几秒钟。
Then suddenly, the antelopes jerk and fly off running. And I turn and see my brother coming up all red and sweaty. We chase them over another little hill. And on the other side, there are now eight of them. So we follow the eight for a little ways. And then they split into three groups that all go in different directions. We can't tell which group has even one of the antelope we started chasing. They all look so much alike, especially from a distance. But we choose two does, and follow them. And they run over another little hill. And on the other side, all of a sudden, there are 20 of them, running as a herd.
然后突然，羚羊抽搐了一下，飞奔而去。我转过身，看见我哥哥满脸通红、大汗淋漓地赶上来。我们追着它们翻过另一座小山。在另一边，现在有八只了。所以我们跟着这八只走了一段路。然后它们分成了三组，朝着不同的方向跑去。我们甚至无法分辨哪一组里有我们最初追的那一只。它们看起来太像了，尤其是在远处看的时候。但我们选了两只母羚羊，紧随其后。它们跑过另一座小山。在另一边，突然出现了20只，成群结队地奔跑。
Following this herd is like following a school of fish. They blend and flow and change positions. There are no individuals, but a mass that moves across the desert like a pool of mercury on a glass table. They split again, burst into five pieces, and it's just too confusing. We can't tell whether we're chasing animals that have run for two minutes or 20 minutes or two hours.
跟着这群羚羊就像跟着一群鱼。它们融合、流动、改变位置。没有个体，只有一团像玻璃桌上的水银池一样在沙漠中移动。它们再次分裂，爆发出五个部分，这太令人困惑了。我们无法分辨我们是在追赶跑了两分钟的、20分钟的还是两小时的动物。
I catch up with my brother. And he says, "Man, did you see them run? They just zoom, and they're gone." I ask him how we're going to get around how they group up and split like that. And he says, "I don't know. I've been thinking about it. And I don't know."
我追上了我哥哥。他说：“天哪，你看到它们跑了吗？它们一闪就不见了。”我问他我们要如何应对它们那样聚在一起又分开的情况。他说：“我不知道。我一直在想这个问题。我不知道。”
"Well, what do you think we should do?" I ask him. And he says, "I think we should try it again. Let's go find some more." And so we do. We chase them on and off for two days. But basically, they just ditch us every time.
“那你想我们该怎么办？”我问他。他说：“我想我们应该再试一次。我们去找更多吧。”我们就这样做了。我们断断续续追了它们两天。但基本上，它们每次都把我们甩掉了。
My brother has gone away to get a PhD at a big university back east. The campus is flat and surrounded by trees. He no longer thinks about chasing antelope. He studies lizards now. I stay in Salt Lake, pacing my life by the changing traffic lights, the blinking turn signals, the bouncing checks. I have no desire to participate in the market economy or the democratic process. I have no goals or ambitions other than to someday go back to the desert with my brother and try again to run down an antelope.
我哥哥去东部一所大大学读博士了。校园平坦，周围环绕着树木。他不再考虑追逐羚羊的事了。他现在研究蜥蜴。我留在盐湖城，生活节奏被交通信号灯的变幻、闪烁的转向灯、跳票的支票所控制。我除了梦想有一天能和哥哥回到沙漠再次尝试追捕羚羊外，没有任何参与市场经济或民主进程的渴望或抱负。
I have a plan, and I'm trying to follow it. But it's hard. It's a hard plan to follow. I'm trying to get in shape. And I'm trying to live like a primitive man. Sometimes, I feel like I'm not succeeding at either one. I've read a lot about primitive cultures. And I use that term, "primitive," in the sense that it means original or primary. For maybe 99% of human history, a few million years, humans were hunters. They didn't get up and go to work each morning. That started with civilization. And civilization is nothing but a heartbeat of recent time, 10,000 years at the most. And to hell with that.
我有一个计划，我正在努力执行它。但很难。这是一个很难执行的计划。我正在尝试锻炼身体。我正在尝试像原始人一样生活。有时，我觉得我两者都没成功。我读过很多关于原始文化的书。我使用“原始”这个词，是指它意味着最初的或根本的。在人类历史的大约99%的时间里，几百万年，人类是猎人。他们不是每天早上起床去上班。那是文明开始的事。而文明只是近期时间里的心跳，最多也就1万年。去他的吧。
I want to wake up naked and alone in the desert. I want to eat sand and drink piss and pass out screaming from sunburn and spider bites. But I know it won't work, and I know it won't happen, either because I'm a coward, or unable, or it's just not possible at all for anyone. Even if I were to wake up naked and alone in the wilderness, I'd still wake up thinking and making sense of myself and the world around me in modern English. And there's no way I can get around that. So I'm stuck with choosing not to participate, to live apart in any way I can think of. My wife used to like it. I think maybe that's why she wanted to marry me. But now we have kids, and she sort of changed her mind.
我想在沙漠中赤身裸体、独自醒来。我想吃沙子、喝尿，因为晒伤和蜘蛛叮咬而尖叫着昏死过去。但我知道这行不通，我也知道这不会发生，要么是因为我是个懦夫，或者能力不足，要么对任何人来说这根本就不可能。即使我真的在荒野中赤身裸体、独自醒来，我醒来时仍会用现代英语思考并解读我自己和周围的世界。我无法绕过这一点。所以我只能选择不参与，尽可能地过离群索居的生活。我妻子过去很喜欢这样。我想也许这就是她想嫁给我的原因。但现在我们有了孩子，她多少改变了主意。
I try to get in shape by running in the mountains and skiing cross country. I smoke marijuana and eat LSD and go out and try to go farther farther. And at best, I eventually get lost and deeply humbled, and almost die trying to make it back. This is my training. And at times, not that infrequently, when I'm out there, I feel like I've made the right choice, and that I'm learning a lot and getting stronger. But most the time, I'm not out there. Most of the time, I'm down in the city slaving away and feeling depressed.
我通过在山上跑步和越野滑雪来锻炼身体。我抽大麻、吃LSD，然后走出去尝试跑得更远。最好的情况下，我最终会迷路，受到深刻的羞辱，差点在回来的路上送命。这就是我的训练。有时，并不那么罕见，当我身处野外时，我觉得我做出了正确的选择，并且学到了很多，变得更强壮了。但大多数时候，我并不在野外。大多数时候，我都在城市里辛苦工作，感到沮丧。
Perhaps my best success so far is realizing that I can get lost and almost die without ever leaving home. And that the best test of endurance is just to persist, or rather to insist from day to day in believing that it is possible to run down an antelope. And that it must be done, and that I am the one who must do it.
或许我目前为止最好的成就就是意识到我可以迷路并差点死掉，而无需离开家。最好的耐力考验只是坚持，或者说每天坚持相信追捕羚羊是可能的。这必须完成，而我就是必须完成它的人。
1992. I've read everything I can find in the university library that's been written on antelope, which really isn't all that much. They're still somewhat mysterious and unknown animals, even for the scientists who study them. According to Stan Lindstedt, a biologist living in Flagstaff, Arizona, the pronghorn are the best endurance athletes in the world.
1992年。我读遍了大学图书馆里所有关于羚羊的资料，其实也没多少。它们仍然是某种神秘而未知的动物，即使是对研究它们的科学家来说也是如此。据住在亚利桑那州弗拉格斯塔夫（Flagstaff）的生物学家斯坦·林斯特德（Stan Lindstedt）说，叉角羚是世界上最好的耐力运动员。
They metabolize oxygen at a rate three and a half times higher than even the finest human runners. They have twice as much blood, and their hearts and lungs are three times the size of a mammal of comparable weight. They can run the equivalent of a marathon in 40 minutes, and can easily maintain a speed of 40 miles an hour for more than 60 minutes. They have no body fat whatsoever.
它们代谢氧气的速度比最优秀的人类跑步者还要快三倍半。它们的血液量是人类的两倍，心脏和肺部大小相当于同等体重哺乳动物的三倍。它们能在40分钟内跑完相当于马拉松的距离，并且能轻松维持时速40英里的速度超过60分钟。它们体内根本没有任何脂肪。
In 1850, there were 60 million antelope in North America, but they were nearly wiped out along with the Buffalo. There are about a million left today. They're said to have 10x vision, which means that, on a clear night, they can see the rings of Saturn. They eat mainly sagebrush, but also rabbitbrush, salt sage, winterfat, fourwing [? saltbush, ?] and fireweed, summer cypress. I'm trying to learn what these plants look like.
1850年，北美有6000万只羚羊，但它们和水牛一起几乎被灭绝了。今天还剩下大约100万只。据说它们有10倍的视力，这意味着在晴朗的夜晚，它们能看到土星环。它们主要吃鼠尾草，但也吃兔刷木、盐鼠尾草、冬脂、四翅盐生草和火焰草、夏柏。我正在尝试学习这些植物长什么样。
1993. I found an old ethnography dated 1935 on the Tarahumara, one of the tribes my brother said can run down big game. And he's right. It seems that they at least used to do it. This is a passage from the book. "The Tarahumara keep the deer constantly on the move. Only occasionally does he get a glimpse of his quarry, but follows it unerringly through his own canny ability to read the tracks. The Indian chases the deer until the creature falls from exhaustion, often with its hooves completely worn away. It's then throttled by the man or killed by the dogs."
1993年。我找到了一本1935年的关于塔拉乌马拉人的旧民族志，这是我哥哥说能追捕大型猎物的部落之一。他是对的。看来他们至少曾经能做到。这是书中的一段话。“塔拉乌马拉人让鹿不断处于移动中。只有偶尔他才能瞥见他的猎物，但凭借他自己解读足迹的精明能力， unerringly地跟踪它。印第安人追赶鹿直到这只生物因精疲力竭而倒下，通常蹄子都完全磨损了。然后它被那个人勒死或被狗杀死。”
But then of course, this was written by a couple of anthropologists who didn't actually go out and hunt with the Indians. And so their report is basically hearsay. There's no way to know whether it's actually true. There seems to be no doubt, though, that the Tarahumara are crazy about running.
但当然，这是由几位并没有真正去和印第安人一起打猎的人类学家写的。所以他们的报告基本上是道听途说。没有办法知道这是否真的属实。不过，毫无疑问，塔拉乌马拉人对跑步有着狂热。
Another ethnography I found describes these races they had where a group of men from a village eat peyote and smear themselves with white grease and run as a team, tossing a leather ball the size of a Hacky Sack down a trail with their toes. They run for three days, close to 300 miles. And the winning team gets to sleep with all the available women in the local village. This is the way I want to live.
我找到的另一本民族志描述了他们举行的那些比赛，一群村里的男人吃佩奥特碱，在身上涂抹白色油脂，像团队一样奔跑，用脚趾沿途投掷一个像Hacky Sack大小的皮球。他们跑三天，将近300英里。获胜的队伍可以和当地村子里所有可用的女性睡觉。这就是我想要的生活方式。
1991. My brother spent five years in Ann Arbor, Michigan, trying to get a PhD. And it seems like the whole thing is killing him. He's developed a heart condition called a ventricular fibrillation, which means that the upper and lower chambers beat out of sync with each other, and his blood doesn't circulate.
1991年。我哥哥在密歇根州安阿伯（Ann Arbor）花了五年时间试图获得博士学位。看起来整件事都在折磨他。他患上了一种叫室颤的心脏病，这意味着心房和心室不同步跳动，血液无法循环。
It happens only for short periods. And it happens only when he's really tired or extremely tense and nervous, like when he runs too far or right before he has to defend his dissertation. He suddenly feels woozy and has to sit down. Sometimes he passes out.
这种情况只持续很短的时间。而且只发生在当他非常疲劳或极度紧张不安时，比如当他跑得太远或在不得不为论文辩护之前。他会突然感到头晕，不得不坐下。有时他会晕过去。
I've written a letter to his advisor, and I've come to Ann Arbor to hand deliver it. "Dear Dr. Renzer, I assume that you're aware of my brother's heart condition and probably even believe you understand the pathology involved. Let me be perfectly clear. If my brother dies while under your supervision, you can kiss your own sweet ass goodbye."
我写了一封信给他的导师，并亲自送到安阿伯。“亲爱的伦泽（Renzer）博士，我假设你知道我哥哥的心脏状况，甚至可能相信你了解其中涉及的病理。让我说得非常清楚。如果我哥哥在你的监管下死亡，你可以滚蛋了。”
I drive into town late Sunday night, and the doors to the biology building are locked. I've been here a couple times before, and I sort of remember where my brother's lab is located. So I take a guess and throw a rock at a window, and it's his, and he's there.
我周日深夜开车进城，生物大楼的门锁着。我以前来过几次，隐约记得我哥哥的实验室在哪里。所以我猜了一下，往窗户扔了一块石头，那是他的实验室，他就在那儿。
In his lab, on a table, is a three-foot monitor lizard lying perfectly still except for an occasional blink of an eye. Two tiny wires are dangling out of its rib cage. He's anesthetized it and implanted electrodes into its intercostal muscles, the muscles along the rib cage.
在他的实验室里，桌子上有一只三英尺长的巨蜥，除了一眨眼外一动不动。两根细小的导线从它的胸腔垂下。他给它做了麻醉，并将电极植入了它的肋间肌，就是肋骨边缘的肌肉。
He puts the lizard in its box and takes me to the basement, where he has built a long runway of plywood and two by fours. He has another lizard down there, and he takes it out of the cage and holds it and puts it on his shoulder. And it jumps from there through three feet of air and lands on the wall and sticks to the cinder block like Spider-Man. He yanks it off the wall and puts it at one end of the runway. "Watch how its backbone moves when it runs," he says. Then he touches its tail, and it blasts off down the track. Its backbone waves like a plucked guitar string.
他把蜥蜴放进盒子里，带我去了地下室，他在那里用胶合板和木方搭了一个长跑道。他下面还有另一只蜥蜴，他把它从笼子里取出来抱在肩上。它从那里跳过三英尺的空中，落在墙上，像蜘蛛侠一样粘在煤渣砖上。他把它从墙上拽下来，放在跑道的一端。“看它跑步时脊骨是怎么动的，”他说。然后他碰了碰它的尾巴，它就沿着跑道冲了出去。它的脊骨像拨动的吉他弦一样波动。
My brother says, "I thought that lizards probably can't breathe when they run, that the way they bend like that would make it impossible." "And do they?" I ask. "Nope. Looks like they can't run and breathe at the same time." "So why is it taking you so long?" I say. "Why have you been doing this for five years?" He says he's upset some people, some dinosaur people, and that he's had to go back and do all of his experiments all over again. I ask him why the dinosaur people are upset. And he tells me, but I don't understand a word of it.
我哥哥说：“我以为蜥蜴跑步时可能没法呼吸，它们那样弯曲的方式可能使这变得不可能。”“它们做到了吗？”我问。“没有。看起来它们没法同时奔跑和呼吸。”“那为什么花了你这么长时间？”我说。“你为什么已经做这个五年了？”他说他惹恼了一些人，一些研究恐龙的人，他不得不回去重新做所有的实验。我问他为什么研究恐龙的人会生气。他告诉了我，但我一个字也没听懂。
I tell him I'm going to Mexico to run down a deer with the Tarahumara. I tell him it could be like science to actually record how they do it, that it would be the first and only record, a first hand experience, and so on. But he says there's no way he can go, no way he can leave his work. He doesn't even seem interested. And I drive out of town without delivering the letter and thinking, now it's just me. Now, I'm in this alone.
我告诉他我要去墨西哥和塔拉乌马拉人一起追捕鹿。我告诉他，记录他们是怎么做的简直就像科学一样，这将是第一个也是唯一的记录，第一手的体验等等。但他却说他没法去，没法离开他的工作。他看起来甚至不感兴趣。我离开小镇时没有递交那封信，心里想，现在只剩我了。现在，我是孤身一人了。
Scott Carrier heads to Mexico to run after antelopes with native peoples there. In a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
斯科特·卡里尔前往墨西哥与当地人一起追捕羚羊。稍后从公共广播国际台（Public Radio International），节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Our program today, people who battle nature with the possibility of losing. We return to Scott Carrier's story about his 12-year quest, Running After Antelope.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目每周都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。我们今天的节目讲述的是人们与自然抗争，并可能面临失败的故事。我们回到斯科特·卡里尔关于他12年追逐梦想的故事——“追逐羚羊”。
1994. I'm always ready to go. I have a map nearly memorized. I have an English-Tarahumara dictionary that I keep checking out from the university library. I'm ready if I can only get the money, and if I can only get the time. But I never do. And it never happens. And now, all of a sudden, the Tarahumara have come to Salt Lake and are staying at my house. There are four of them, men between 25 and 35 years old. And they're here to run in a 100 mile race through the Wasatch mountains.
1994年。我随时准备出发。我已经快把地图背下来了。我有一本英-塔拉乌马拉字典，一直在从大学图书馆借阅。只要我能筹到钱，只要我能挤出时间，我就准备好了。但我从没做到。这件事也从没发生。而现在，突然之间，塔拉乌马拉人来到了盐湖城，住在我家里。他们有四个人，年龄在25到35岁之间的男性。他们来到这里是为了参加一场穿过瓦萨奇山脉（Wasatch mountains）的100英里比赛。
I'm in the process of tearing the house apart like always. And there's no electricity, because I'm redoing the service connection. We don't even have a wire from the pole. But this is a good thing, I think, something that'll make the Tarahumara feel at home. They don't have electricity. They don't even have outhouses. Their manager is a back country tour guide from Tucson, Arizona. And he tells me he's brought them here to raise money and get media attention for their families back home, who are all starving to death.
我像往常一样正在把房子拆得乱七八糟。而且没有电，因为我正在重做线路连接。我们甚至连从电线杆引过来的电线都没有。但我认为这很好，这会让塔拉乌马拉人感到宾至如归。他们没有电。他们甚至连厕所都没有。他们的经理是来自亚利桑那州图森市（Tucson）的荒野导游。他告诉我，他带他们来这里是为了筹款，并为他们在家乡快要饿死的家人们争取媒体关注。
The Tarahumara are wearing their traditional clothing of long, white shirts, held at the waste by a belt, and a pair of sandals cut from truck tires. They appear to be healthy enough, but I can't really tell. They're silent. They look mainly at the ground. And they move around my house as a unit, even to the bathroom. They look more frightened than malnourished.
塔拉乌马拉人穿着传统的服装，长长的白衬衫，腰间系着皮带，还有一双用卡车轮胎剪成的凉鞋。他们看起来还算健康，但我无法确定。他们很沉默。他们主要盯着地面看。他们在我房子里像一个整体一样走动，连上厕所也是。他们看起来比营养不良更像是受到惊吓。
We eat dinner outside, where they seem more comfortable. And afterwards, I ask them through a friend who speaks Spanish if they've ever run down a deer. And they say, no. The deer have disappeared, and they don't know why, but they're gone. I ask them if they know other, older Tarahumara who did do it. And they say, yes, they know it was done. They've heard stories, and that the technique was to chase them for two or three days, taking turns and trading off and even sleeping and tracking them down to start again in the morning. Eventually, the deer would stop and let them put a rope around its neck. And then they'd kill it.
我们在外面吃晚饭，在那里他们似乎更自在。饭后，我通过一位会西班牙语的朋友问他们是否曾经追捕过鹿。他们说，没有。鹿已经消失了，他们不知道为什么，但它们不见了。我问他们是否认识更老、曾经这样做过的塔拉乌马拉人。他们说，是的，他们知道这确实发生过。他们听过故事，技巧是追逐它们两三天，轮流交替，甚至睡觉也会跟踪，早上接着追。最终，鹿会停下来，让他们把绳子套在它的脖子上。然后他们会杀死它。
Two days later, three of the four Tarahumara finished first, second, and fourth in the race, all running the 100 miles, up and down through the mountains, in less than 21 hours.
两天后，四名塔拉乌马拉人中有三名在比赛中获得了第一、第二和第四名，都在21小时内跑完了100英里，翻越山脉。
1995. When I drive across the desert, I look for antelope standing by the highway. One time, on I-80 in Wyoming, I saw three of them outrun a freight train. In northwestern Nevada, there were at least 50, a huge herd, running alongside my car. They flew out ahead and across the road like a river going 60 miles an hour. Again in Wyoming, at night, I saw what looked like a cluster of luminescent grapes along the road, and then realized it was antelope eyes, a group of them, hanging out and watching the traffic like a drive-in movie. And then, in the Great Salt Lake Desert, I saw a lone male standing motionless and staring while four F16 fighter jets flew low over its head on their way to the bombing range.
1995年。当我开车穿越沙漠时，我会寻找站在公路旁的羚羊。有一次，在怀俄明州的80号州际公路上，我看到三只羚羊跑赢了一列货运火车。在内华达州西北部，至少有50只，一大群，在我车旁奔跑。它们像一条时速60英里的河流，飞速跃向前方并穿过公路。又是在怀俄明州，晚上，我看到路边有一串看起来像发光葡萄的东西，后来才意识到那是羚羊的眼睛，一群羚羊在那里像看汽车影院一样看着过往车辆。然后，在大盐湖沙漠（Great Salt Lake Desert），我看到一只公羚羊站着不动，盯着天空，这时四架F16战斗机低空飞过它的头顶，飞往轰炸靶场。
I've been watching that lone male for a couple of years now. He's part of a small herd of maybe 12 to 16 that I can always find in a place called Puddle Valley, a no man's land just west of the Great Salt Lake, just east of the Bonneville Salt Flats, just south of the Hill Air Force base bombing range, and just north of the Dugway Proving Grounds, where the army tests biological and chemical weapons. There's one paved road that runs up the valley, and the antelope are nearly always standing alongside the road, if not right on the asphalt itself. They'll walk slowly away if I stop and get out of the car, but otherwise they just stand there and look at me, only 30 yards away.
我已经观察那只独居公羚羊几年了。它是小群（大约12到16只）中的一部分，我总能在“水坑谷”（Puddle Valley）找到它们，那是一片位于大盐湖以西、博纳维尔盐滩（Bonneville Salt Flats）以东、希尔空军基地轰炸靶场以南、达格韦试验场（Dugway Proving Grounds，军队测试生物和化学武器的地方）以北的“无主之地”。有一条铺装路通往山谷，羚羊几乎总是站在路边，如果不是站在沥青路面上本身的话。如果我停车下车，它们会慢慢走开，但除此之外它们只是站在那里看着我，离我只有30码远。
I've been thinking that this herd would be a lot easier to chase because there are so few of them. And that I've been watching the lone male enough that I think I could recognize him at a distance, in case he tried to group up and split like the ones did before. His horns are more shaped like a heart than the others. And he has a brown line on his chest that curls around like a question mark. I call him the lone male, because I've only seen him once with the others. And this was in the fall when he was rutting with two does, going from one to the other with a hard-on, kicking up dirt, pissing and [BLEEP] and marking plants with the scent gland on his cheek.
我一直在想，这群羚羊会更容易追，因为它们的数量太少了。而且我观察这只独居公羚羊已经足够多，以至于我觉得在远处也能认出它，以防它像以前那些一样聚在一起又分开。它的角比其他的更像心形。它的胸前有一条棕色的线，卷起来像个问号。我叫它“独居公羚羊”，因为我只见过它和别的羚羊在一起一次。那是在秋天，它正和两只母羚羊发情，从这一只跑到那一只，硬着阳具，踢起尘土，撒尿、[哔——]并在脸颊的香腺上标记植物。
Once, in early spring, I saw him through my binoculars from a half mile away. He was looking right back at me, so I knelt down a little bit so my head was just below his line of sight. I waited for 10 minutes or so and then stood up slowly and peeked. And he was standing there looking at me, but much closer, maybe only a quarter of a mile away. So I sat down and waited some more. And he came to within 100 yards. So I laid flat and waited. And I could hear him in the sagebrush barking at me like a sharp cough. [SHARP COUGH SOUND] He came real close, less than 30 yards away, and I stood up. And he didn't take off. He just stood there and barked at me, scratched the dirt with his front leg, then slowly wandered off.
有一次，在初春，我用望远镜在半英里外看到它。它正盯着我看，所以我跪下来一点，让我的头刚好低于它的视线。我等了大约10分钟，然后慢慢站起来窥视。它正站在那里看着我，但离得更近了，可能只有四分之一英里远。所以我坐下来又等了一会儿。它来到100码以内。所以我躺平又等了一会儿。我能听到它在鼠尾草丛里对我吠叫，像尖锐的咳嗽声。[尖锐的咳嗽声]它靠得非常近，不到30码远，我站了起来。它没有跑。它只是站在那里对我吠叫，用前腿抓着地，然后慢慢走开了。
There are two dominant theories of human evolution, and neither theory involves running. Both theories basically say that humans stood upright so they'd be able to use their hands to pick stuff up, either tools or weapons or food or infants. There's probably some truth in that idea, but I just can't believe that it's the whole story. I can't believe that running isn't part of it. For one thing, tools don't show up in the archaeological record until 2 million years after hominids first walked upright. If my brother's right, and if one of the reasons hominids stood upright-- one of the reasons humans separated from apes and became human-- is that standing upright gave them more endurance as runners for chasing game, this seems true to me at a basic level that's hard to explain. When my brother and I were out chasing antelope, it felt different and more fundamental than anything I'd ever done. I felt connected and whole, as if I had nothing, and nothing was everything I needed.
关于人类进化有两种主导理论，没有一种理论涉及奔跑。两种理论基本上都说人类直立行走是为了能够用手拿东西，无论是工具、武器、食物还是婴儿。这种观点里可能有一些道理，但我就是无法相信这就是全部故事。我无法相信跑步不是其中的一部分。一方面，工具直到原始人直立行走200万年后才出现在考古记录中。如果我哥哥是对的，如果原始人直立行走的原因之一——人类与猿类分离并成为人类的原因之一——是直立行走让他们作为奔跑者追捕猎物时拥有更多耐力，这对我来说在最基本的层面上似乎是真实的，难以解释。当我和哥哥在外面追逐羚羊时，它感觉比我做过的任何事情都更不同、更根本。我感到与一切相连、完整，好像我什么都没有，而“什么都没有”就是我需要的一切。
1997. After two years of passing paper back and forth with the IRS, I have formed a nonprofit corporation to raise money for a trip to visit the Seri Indians in Mexico. The Seris live on and near Tiburon Island in the Sea of Cortez, just inside the Baja peninsula. And like the Tarahumara, they are said to have been able to run down deer. But the Seris are said to be even more wild and more reclusive and more unaffected by civilization. I wrote a proposal for the expedition and sent it out to a lot of foundations and government agencies. And not one responded.
1997年。在与国税局（IRS）往返了两年文件之后，我成立了一个非营利组织，为去墨西哥拜访塞里印第安人（Seri Indians）的旅行筹集资金。塞里人住在科尔特斯海（Sea of Cortez）中提布隆岛（Tiburon Island）及其附近，就在下加利福尼亚半岛内侧。和塔拉乌马拉人一样，据说他们曾经能够追捕鹿。但据说塞里人更狂野、更孤僻，更不受文明的影响。我为探险写了一份提案，并寄给了许多基金会和政府机构。没有一家回应。
But now, the American Express company, out of the blue, has given me a corporate gold card with no apparent credit limit, so we're leaving. In two months, someone from the American Express company will call and inquire about a payment in full. But two months is such a long time, an inconceivable time when you're driving south into the Sonoran desert.
但现在，美国运通公司（American Express）突然给了我一张没有明确信用额度的公司金卡，所以我们出发了。两个月后，美国运通公司会有人打电话来询问全额付款。但两个月是很长的时间，当你开车向南进入索诺兰沙漠（Sonoran desert）时，这简直是无法想象的时间。
I would have liked for my brother to come along. But he has just been hired by the University of Utah as a professor in the biology department. He came to town with five dogs, 15 sturgeon fish, four five-foot alligators, and two iguanas. And he's busy setting up his laboratory and preparing his lectures. So I've asked my friend, Creighton King, to come in his place.
我本来希望我哥哥能一起去。但他刚被犹他大学生物系聘为教授。他带着五条狗、15条鲟鱼、四条五英尺长的短吻鳄和两只鬣蜥来到城里。他正忙着建立实验室和准备讲座。所以我请了我的朋友克雷顿·金（Creighton King）代替他。
Creighton's the best runner I know. He's 43 years old, probably past his prime. But a decade or two ago, he was a virtual wonder of aerobic capacity and endurance, running and skiing, collapsing all previous notions of time and space in the Rocky Mountains. For instance, he once ran back and forth across the Grand Canyon, from the South Rim, down to the river, and up to the North Rim and back-- a distance of 42 miles with more than 22,000 feet of elevation-- in seven and a half hours. I've always thought if anybody could catch an antelope, it'd be Creighton. We've also brought our two sons along, because they're out of school for the summer and old enough now, nine and 11, to come along for the adventure.
克雷顿是我认识的最好的跑步者。他43岁了，可能已经过了巅峰期。但十二十年前，他是健氧能力和耐力的奇迹，跑步和滑雪，摧毁了所有关于洛基山脉时间和空间的既定概念。例如，他曾经在大峡谷来回跑，从南缘到河边，再到北缘再回来——42英里的距离，海拔变化超过22,000英尺——只用了七个半小时。我一直认为如果有人能抓住羚羊，那一定是克雷顿。我们还带上了我们的两个儿子，因为他们暑假不上学，现在9岁和11岁，已经够大可以来参加探险了。
It's a long drive down there, 1,000 miles. And it's hot in Phoenix, in Tucson, hotter still as we cross the border into Mexico. And driving through Hermosillo and west to the ocean, it's simply the hottest place I could ever imagine, at least 110 degrees, if not 120. I keep thinking that my tires or my radiator is going to blow up, that my car-- which has over 250,000 miles on it-- is just not going to make it. And we're going to be stuck in the middle of the desert.
去那里的路很长，1,000英里。凤凰城和图森市很热，穿过边境进入墨西哥后更热。开车穿过埃莫西约（Hermosillo）向西到海边，简直是我能想象到的最热的地方，至少110华氏度，如果不说是120度的话。我一直担心我的轮胎或散热器会爆炸，担心我的车——行驶里程已经超过25万英里——根本撑不过去。而我们将被困在沙漠中间。
I keep thinking I've made a big mistake, that I've spent 12 years being obsessed with a foolish notion, and that I've pushed it to the point of absurdity. And now, we're all going to pay for it, big time.
我一直认为我犯了一个大错，我花了12年时间痴迷于一个愚蠢的念头，我已经把它推到了荒谬的地步。现在，我们所有人都要为此付出惨痛的代价。
But Creighton seems to be not worried at all. And the kids are oblivious to everything but the heat and the strange desert, sun-baked and full of saguaro and [? sajaso ?] cacti holding big osprey nests. They're all having a good time. And I try to relax and let things happen without freaking out. [DOG BARKING]
但克雷顿似乎一点也不担心。孩子们对热和奇怪的沙漠一无所知，他们被晒得焦黄，到处是仙人掌，上面挂着巨大的鹗鸟巢。他们都玩得很开心。我试着放松，让事情自然发生，而不是抓狂。[狗叫声]
There's a small fishing village called Punta Chueca on the coast of the Sea of Cortez with about 200 people, all Seri. They live in cinder block homes painted white and baby blue, with the doors and windows either open or missing altogether and the yards separated by fences made from branches and sticks and worn out fishing nets.
在科尔特斯海岸边有一个叫蓬塔丘卡（Punta Chueca）的小渔村，大约有200人，全都是塞里人。他们住在漆成白色和婴儿蓝的煤渣砖房里，门窗要么开着要么干脆不见了，院子由树枝、棍棒和破旧的渔网做成的篱笆隔开。
We drive slowly through the houses and stop at the beach. Five or six women come and surround us and start speaking to us in Seri, trying to sell us some necklaces made from tiny, brightly colored shells and beautiful, dark red ironwood sculptures of dolphins, sea turtles, and iguanas. We buy a few of them. But they clearly want us to buy them all. We tell them, later, maybe later, that we don't have a lot of money. But they're adamant, putting things in our hands, poking us in the ribs, making it clear we have no use or value to them other than our money.
我们缓慢地开车穿过房子，停在沙滩上。五六个女人围住我们，开始用塞里语跟我们说话，试图卖给我们一些由细小、色彩鲜艳的贝壳做成的项链，以及精美的、深红色的铁木雕刻的海豚、海龟和鬣蜥。我们买了几件。但她们显然想让我们全买下。我们告诉她们，以后，也许以后，我们没有多少钱。但她们很坚持，把东西塞进我们手里，戳我们的肋骨，清楚地表明我们对她们而言除了钱没有任何用途或价值。
[SPEAKING SERI]
[塞里语交谈]
After what seems like quite a long time, we were rescued from the women by a man who comes over and introduces himself as Ernesto Molina, a fisherman and a tourist guide. He's 50 years old and speaks excellent Spanish. He's very calm and soft spoken, a nice change from the women. He says he has been to college in Prescott, Arizona. And we try talking to him in English, and he understands, but he always answers in Spanish.
在过了似乎很长一段时间后，我们被一个走过来做自我介绍的男人从女人们手中解救出来，他是埃内斯托·莫利纳（Ernesto Molina），一名渔夫和导游。他50岁，讲一口流利的西班牙语。他非常冷静且说话轻声细语，与那些女人们形成鲜明的对比。他说他曾在亚利桑那州普雷斯科特（Prescott）上过大学。我们试着用英语和他交谈，他听得懂，但总是用西班牙语回答。
We tell him that we've come because we're interested in learning about how the Seri hunt deer and would like to find someone who could take us over to the island. He says no one lives on the island anymore, that the Mexican government has turned it into a national park, but he can take us over there for a visit. And as far as hunting goes, the Mexican government also prohibits that, but that he's well acquainted with the old ways as he's the grandson of Francisco Molina, guide to the great Charles Sheldon, an American hunter who visited this area in 1921.
我们告诉他我们来这里是因为对学习塞里人如何猎鹿感兴趣，并想找个能带我们去岛上的人。他说岛上已经没人住了，墨西哥政府把它变成了国家公园，但他可以带我们去参观。至于打猎，墨西哥政府也禁止，但他非常熟悉古老的方式，因为他是弗朗西斯科·莫利纳（Francisco Molina）的孙子，弗朗西斯科曾是伟大的美国猎人查尔斯·谢尔顿（Charles Sheldon，1921年造访此地）的导游。
I've read Sheldon's account, and have even brought the book along with me. And I get it out of the car, and Ernesto shows me the photographs of his grandfather, Francisco. He's read the book and knows the passages where Sheldon describes how impressed he was with Francisco's knowledge and strength as a hunter. I'm amazed by our luck. We've been here for less than an hour, and already we've found an excellent guide and translator.
我读过谢尔顿的记述，甚至把书带在身上。我把它从车里拿出来，埃内斯托给我看了他爷爷弗朗西斯科的照片。他读过这本书，知道书里描述谢尔顿对弗朗西斯科作为猎人的知识和力量有多么印象深刻的段落。我被我们的运气惊呆了。我们在这里不到一小时，就已经找到了一位优秀的向导和翻译。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
In the evening, we sit with Ernesto on the beach, and he tells us that yes, it's true, the Seris at one time, before they had rifles, would run after deer until they dropped from exhaustion. The young hunter would be given a special drink of two or three types of plants. He wouldn't say which ones, but it was a power food of some kind to give him strength and fortitude. And then the hunter would go off and track the deer alone.
晚上，我们和埃内斯托坐在沙滩上，他告诉我们是的，这是真的，塞里人在有枪之前，确实会追着鹿直到它们因精疲力竭而倒下。年轻的猎人会被给予一种由两三种植物混合的特殊饮料。他没说具体是哪几种，但那是一种能给他力量和毅力的能量食品。然后猎人会单独去跟踪鹿。
Once he found the deer, he would start running after it in a series of chases. In the first chase, the deer would be frightened and run very quickly and far away. And it took great skill and knowledge to follow it, never losing sight of the animal, making sure he was still following the same animal. And that this was critical and very difficult, to make sure he was always following the same one. Eventually, the hunter would catch up with the deer, and it would run again, this time more slowly and less of a distance, only two or three kilometers.
一旦他找到鹿，他就会开始一系列的追逐。在第一次追逐中，鹿会受到惊吓，跑得非常快、非常远。需要极大的技巧和知识来跟踪它，始终不失去对动物的视线，确保他仍在跟踪同一只动物。这至关重要且非常困难，要确保他跟踪的始终是同一只。最终，猎人会追上鹿，它会再次奔跑，这次跑得更慢，距离也更短，只有两三公里。
And again, the hunter must make sure that he did not lose sight of it, and that it was the same individual. The deer would stop again to rest, and the hunter would catch up with it. And this time, the third time, the deer would realize that the hunter was stronger. And the deer would become disoriented, because although the deer is very smart, it doesn't have the intelligence of a human being. Eventually, the deer would become completely fatigued, beaten down, and sometimes it would fall and not get up. Sometimes the hunter would kill it with a rock. This was the method, he said, the technique that was used. And that is all.
猎人再次必须确保没有失去它的视线，而且是同一只。鹿会再次停下来休息，猎人会追上它。第三次时，鹿会意识到猎人更强。鹿会变得不知所措，因为尽管鹿非常聪明，但它没有人类的智慧。最终，鹿会完全疲惫、崩溃，有时会倒下起不来。有时猎人会用石头杀死它。这就是方法，他说，这就是使用的技术。就这样。
We ask him if he's ever done this, hunted this way. And he says, no, that his grandfather Francisco could do it, but that when he died, the technique died with him. We ask him how he knows for sure that it was done like this. And he says that both his father and his grandfather told him about it. And that they were both great hunters and knew very well the ways of the deer, but that now, there are much fewer deer and that, again, the government doesn't allow them to hunt. He says that there are two elders in the village, the Montano brothers, who also know about the technique, and that we can talk to them tomorrow if we'd like.
我们问他是否曾经这样做过，以这种方式打猎。他说，没有，他爷爷弗朗西斯科能做到，但当他去世时，这门技术也随他而去。我们问他怎么确定以前是这样做的。他说他父亲和爷爷都告诉过他。他们都是伟大的猎人，非常了解鹿的习性，但现在，鹿少得多了，而且还是那句话，政府不允许他们打猎。他说村里有两位长老，蒙塔诺（Montano）兄弟，也知道这门技术，如果我们愿意，明天可以和他们谈谈。
[SPEAKING SERI]
[塞里语交谈]
The next day, we interview Cuy and Chewy Montano. They say they're about 64 and 70 years old, but they don't know for sure, as neither one can remember the month or year they were born. They speak in Seri, translated by Cuy's son. And they tell us basically the same story as Ernesto, that the hunter would chase the deer three or four times. And would take about two, or two and a half hours, and then the deer would collapse.
第二天，我们采访了库伊（Cuy）和切维（Chewy）蒙塔诺。他们说他们大约64和70岁了，但他们无法确定，因为他们谁都不记得自己出生的月份或年份。他们用塞里语交谈，由库伊的儿子翻译。他们基本上告诉我们和埃内斯托一样的故事，猎人会追鹿三四次。这会花大约两到两个半小时，然后鹿就会崩溃。
Creighton asks them if there are any runners in the village, if anyone would like to try this again. And they say, no, that they no longer run, that everything is changed. I ask them if it's better now. And Cuy says, no, not at all. It was better before. That they used to do everything as a family, that the whole community was a family, and that they shared everything and cooperated. But now, there's a lot of arguing and bickering, more like every man for himself.
克雷顿问他们村里还有没有跑步者，有没有人想再试一次。他们说，不，他们不再跑步了，一切都变了。我问他们现在是不是更好。库伊说，不，一点也不。以前更好。他们过去凡事以家庭为单位，整个社区就是一个大家庭，他们共享一切并合作。但现在，有很多争吵和纷争，更像是各人自扫门前雪。
In the morning, Ernesto comes by our camp on the beach with his boat, ready to take us across the channel to Tiburon Island. It takes about an hour to get there. We land and have lunch, and then Creighton and I fill up our water bottles and head out for the mountains to look for deer, leaving the kids with Ernesto. [RUNNING SOUNDS] We run and walk and weave back and forth through the vegetation, which is all nearly leafless and thorny and offers not an inch of shade for protection from the sun. It's so hot and bright and dry, it's hard to believe anything or anybody could survive here for more than a few hours.
早上，埃内斯托开着他的船来到我们沙滩边的营地，准备带我们穿过海峡去提布隆岛。到那里大约需要一小时。我们登陆吃了午饭，然后克雷顿和我装满水瓶，出发去山上找鹿，把孩子们留给了埃内斯托。[跑步声]我们在植被中穿行、跑步、步行，植被几乎都落叶且带刺，提供不了一寸遮荫来保护我们免受阳光照射。这里太热、太亮、太干，很难相信任何生物能在这种地方生存超过几个小时。
We run and walk intermittently for an hour or so, seeing deer tracks and deer scat, but no deer. After a few miles, we get to the foothills and climb a small peak, only about 500 feet high, and look up to the top of the mountain, 5,000 feet higher and maybe 10 miles in the distance. Dark red and ragged volcanic rock, completely barren and forbidding, like the pictures sent back from Mars. We had talked about maybe trying to climb it, but now it's clear we'd never make it in the heat of the day.
我们断断续续地跑步和步行了一个小时左右，看到了鹿的踪迹和鹿粪，但没看到鹿。几英里后，我们到达山脚，爬上了一座只有大约500英尺高的小山峰，抬头望向山顶，那里高出5,000英尺，距离可能在10英里远。深红而参差不齐的火山岩，完全荒芜而令人望而生畏，就像从火星传回的照片。我们曾谈过也许尝试爬上去，但现在很清楚，在酷热的白天我们永远也爬不上去。
Coming up the hill, we both got stabbed in the shins by cacti, Creighton not so bad, but my leg is a mess.
上山时，我们的小腿都被仙人掌刺到了，克雷顿还没那么惨，但我的腿简直是一团糟。
Ow, that hurts. They got little--
噢，好痛。它们有小的……
Little barbs on the end. They don't' want to come out. I had to use a stick.
末端有小倒钩。它们不想出来。我不得不动用一根树枝。
The quills are like a pocupine's, a couple of inches long and with a barb that makes them move deeper and deeper. I start pulling them out, and blood's running down into my socks. And the skin is swelling up with toxin, like I'd been bit by a rattlesnake. As we're sitting there, we realize that just next to us is a small, cleared out circle ringed by a low wall of rocks piled up for a wind break. Maybe it was a campsite. And there are some broken pieces of pottery, really thin but big, like from a jug to carry water. We can see out across the channel to the mainland, and then north and south maybe 100 miles, a perfect place to sit and wait for inspiration.
刺像豪猪的一样，几英寸长，带着倒钩，使它们越扎越深。我开始把它们拔出来，血顺着流进了袜子里。皮肤因为毒素而肿了起来，就像被响尾蛇咬了一样。当我们坐在那里时，我们意识到我们旁边就是一个被一圈低矮岩石墙包围的小圆圈，那是为了挡风堆起来的。也许那曾是个露营地。还有一些破碎的陶片，非常薄但很大，就像装水的水罐碎片。我们可以看到海峡对面的大陆，向北和向南可以看到大约100英里，这里是个坐着等待灵感的完美地方。
We sit in silence for awhile. And I'm trying to believe that we're doing the right thing, that we're doing what we've come here for. But really, honestly, I want to go back and leave the island and drive home. I'm hot, so hot my brains are boiling. And I don't care about hunting anymore. Coming down here, I was thinking that maybe the Seris were still like they used to be, and that maybe we could find the last surviving wild men on the planet. But that was foolish, just a dream or a delusion. And I've just woken up. And the whole thing has disappeared in front of me.
我们沉默地坐了一会儿。我试着相信我们正在做正确的事，我们正在做我们来这里要实现的目标。但老实说，我想回去，离开这个岛，开车回家。我太热了，大脑都在沸腾。我再也不在乎打猎了。来这里之前，我以为塞里人可能还和以前一样，也许我们可以找到地球上最后幸存的野生人。但这很愚蠢，只是一个梦想或幻想。我刚刚醒悟过来。这一切就在我面前消失了。
There are no more primitive hunters left anywhere. It's a dead thing, surviving only as a story in a few old people's heads. And when they're gone, it'll be gone and lost forever. It now seems ridiculous to try to run down an antelope. I tell Creighton that maybe this is it, that this is as far as we should go, that it's time to go home. And he agrees, and we start back.
世界上再也没有原始猎人了。那是个消亡的东西，只存在于几个老人的头脑中作为故事。当他们走了，它也将永远消失。现在尝试追捕羚羊看起来简直可笑。我告诉克雷顿，也许这就是极限了，这就是我们应该走到的地方，是时候回家了。他同意了，我们开始往回走。
1997. On a Sunday in July, I am eating dinner at my mother's house in Salt Lake, and I mentioned to my brother that Creighton and I are going out to the desert west of the lake next week to try chasing antelope again. I tell him Creighton was inspired by the Seri, that he's been running a lot since we got back. And I'd feel like a flake if I didn't go with him, just go out one more time and try it. I tell my brother this without any conviction, without expecting him to be interested. But to my surprise, he is interested. He says he wants to go, that he had other plans but he'll change them. He even seems hurt I wouldn't think about including him. And I say, "Yeah. OK, good. Let's do it."
1997年。7月的一个周日，我在盐湖城的母亲家吃晚饭，我跟我哥哥提到克雷顿和我下周要到湖西边的沙漠去尝试再次追赶羚羊。我告诉他克雷顿受到塞里人的启发，自从我们回来后他就一直在跑步。如果我不和他一起去，只去最后一次再试一次，我会觉得像个逃兵。我毫无信念地对哥哥说了这些，也没指望他会感兴趣。但令我吃惊的是，他很感兴趣。他说他想去，他本来有别的计划但会更改。他甚至因为我没想过把他包括在内而感到受伤。我说：“好的，没问题。我们做吧。”
Does it make any sense to even bother?
就算去做了，哪怕有一点意义吗？
To start off in that kind of a--
从那种……开始
Yeah, like a net almost.
是的，就像网一样。
So everybody starts from the same place.
所以每个人都从同一个地方开始。
There are five of us, my brother, Creighton, myself, and our friends Calvin and Brian, who are also excellent runners. We are camped on a hillside overlooking the valley, a wide basin 10 miles in diameter, not a tree in sight, ringed by mountains maybe 1,500 feet tall. It's 2 o'clock and 100 degrees. And we're trying to decide on a strategy.
我们有五个人，我哥哥、克雷顿、我，还有我们的朋友卡尔文（Calvin）和布莱恩（Brian），他们也是优秀的跑步者。我们在俯瞰山谷的山坡上扎营，这是一个直径10英里的宽阔盆地，看不到一棵树，四周环绕着可能1,500英尺高的山脉。现在是下午2点，气温100度。我们正在商量战略。
Don't we want to head them towards that little-- that way?
我们不想把它们往那个小……那个方向赶吗？
I think we should try to head them--
我想我们应该试着把它们往……
They've got a big advantage whenever there are hills.
只要有山，它们就有巨大优势。
Yeah, because their Max VO2 is way--
是啊，因为它们的最大摄氧量远……
Creighton and I know how the Seri chased deer. They told us. But now, now that we could use the information, neither one of us brings it up. Somehow, it doesn't seem to apply here. What we end up doing is this. We drive down a road in two cars and find the lone male standing 30 feet off the road. We drive by like we're not interested and stop about a mile away, and get out and argue some more about how we're going to do this. Then, we get back in the cars, and drive back to the lone male, and stop on opposite sides of it, and then pile out of the cars and start chasing it. [RUNNING SOUNDS]
克雷顿和我了解塞里人是如何猎鹿的。他们告诉过我们。但现在，既然我们可以利用这些信息，我们俩都没提。不知何故，它在这里似乎不适用。我们最终做的是：我们分两辆车沿路行驶，发现那只独居公羚羊站在离路30英尺远的地方。我们像没兴趣一样开车经过，停在离它大约一英里远的地方，下车，又争论了一番该怎么做。然后，我们回到车里，开回到独居公羚羊那里，停在它相反的两侧，然后从车里涌出来，开始追它。[跑步声]
It runs due west, and we spread out in a long line that quickly becomes like a V, because Creighton's a much faster runner than any of us. My brother stays behind him. And I start running north, hoping that the antelope will turn clockwise, and I'll be able to cut him off. I run and sometimes stop and look and see the antelope and Creighton and my brother still going west. I run and stop and don't see anything. And I take out my binoculars-- the same power as what the antelope sees-- and search around and finally see a white spot going north. It's the white ass of the antelope with no body attached to it, just a white spot swimming through a mirage, a heat wave above the sagebrush.
它正西跑去，我们排成一个长队散开，很快变成了一个“V”字形，因为克雷顿比我们任何人都跑得快。我哥哥紧跟在他后面。我开始向北跑，希望羚羊会顺时针转弯，我能截住它。我跑了，有时停下来观察，看到羚羊、克雷顿和我哥哥还在向西。我跑了又停，什么也没看到。我拿出双筒望远镜——和羚羊视野同样倍率——四处搜寻，终于看到一个白点向北移动。那是羚羊的白屁股，没有身体，只是一个游泳穿过海市蜃楼（鼠尾草丛上方的热浪）的白点。
I scan to the south and see Creighton, a small beetle in pursuit. Farther behind, another beetle, my brother. They're heading north, so I turn east and run about a half hour. And I come back to the highway. I stop and look around and see my truck two miles down the road, but no antelope, no people. I stand there for a little while and wait, wondering what to do. And then, I just see it as it jumps off the road and down into a sandwash, just see its antlers and white tail, the antelope.
我向南扫描，看到克雷顿，一个追求中的小甲虫。后面更远的地方，另一个甲虫，是我哥哥。它们正向北去，所以我向东转，跑了大约半小时。我回到公路上。我停下来四处看了看，看到我的卡车在两英里外的路上，但没有羚羊，没有人。我就站在那里等了一会儿，不知道该怎么办。然后，我看到它跳下公路钻进一个沙洗渠，只看到它的鹿角和白尾巴，羚羊。
I start after it, realizing that the others are far away, and it's up to me now. The antelope has run for almost an hour and covered maybe 20 miles in 100 degree heat. I've run maybe a quarter of that distance, and I have water on my back that I've been drinking the whole time. If there is any human advantage, like my brother thought there might be, I should certainly have it now.
我开始追它，意识到其他人远在天边，现在全靠我了。羚羊在100度的高温下跑了近一个小时，覆盖了大约20英里。我跑了那段距离的四分之一左右，我背着水，一直在喝。如果像我哥哥想的那样有什么人类优势的话，我现在肯定有。
This is the moment I've been waiting for, and the thought both exhilarates and sickens me. I run, thinking, this is it. He did just what I thought he would. This is the whole thing right now. And I laugh. I laugh and run. And it is, for sure, the best thing I've ever done. I have everything I need. The wilderness is unfolding in front of me.
这是我一直在等待的时刻，这个想法既让我兴奋又让我恶心。我跑着，想着，就是现在。它做到了我以为它会做的一切。这就是全部了。我笑了。我笑着跑着。这确实是我做过的最棒的事。我有我需要的一切。荒野在我面前展开。
Scott Carrier, in Salt Lake City.
斯科特·卡里尔，在盐湖城。
Act Two, Natural Disaster. Now, the story of two men battling the forces of nature in one of the most antiseptic, controlled environments possible, the studio of a late night talk show. On August 8, the show, Late Night with Conan O'Brien broadcast-- what I consider, anyway-- to be the single most interesting hour of television this year. It was daring. It was unprecedented. It was an experiment.
第二幕，“自然灾害”。现在，讲述两个人在一个最无菌、最受控的环境——深夜脱口秀演播室里与自然力量抗争的故事。8月8日，那期《柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀》播出——我认为它是今年最有趣的一个小时的电视节目。它很大胆。它是前所未有的。它是一个实验。
They basically just filled their studio audience with eight-year-olds. And it got so chaotic that at times, Conan O'Brien literally had to tell the audience to pay attention to what was happening on stage. A typical moment in the show-- Conan would tell a very adult joke, a normal, talk show, monologue joke about OJ or the economy. And then he would pause a beat. And you could just feel-- even over the television-- you could feel that nobody in the room knew what he was talking about. It was almost like performance art. And then I guess an applause light would go off somewhere. And then the kids would scream and they would clap. It was almost like a critique of a talk show.
他们基本上只是让演播室的观众席坐满了八岁孩子。情况变得非常混乱，以至于有时柯南·奥布莱恩不得不从字面上告诉观众注意舞台上正在发生什么。节目中的典型时刻——柯南会讲一个非常成人的笑话，一个关于OJ或经济的普通脱口秀独白笑话。然后他会停顿一下。你甚至可以通过电视感觉到——房间里没有人知道他在说什么。这几乎像表演艺术。然后我想可能哪里有个掌声灯灭了。接着孩子们尖叫起来并鼓掌。这几乎是对脱口秀的一种批判。
And then after a bunch of regular adult jokes, they would throw in a joke like this.
然后在一堆常规成人笑话后，他们会加入像这样的笑话。
Finally, last thing I'll mention before we get started kids, Barbra Streisand-- you all know her from Yentl , right?
最后，在开始之前我要提最后一件事，孩子们，芭芭拉·史翠珊（Barbra Streisand）——你们都从《燕特尔》（Yentl）认识她吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah? Barbara Streisand has asked the E Network's gossip show not to call her Babs anymore. That's right, she does not want to be called Babs anymore. Yeah. The only problem is now they've started calling her poopyhead. And I thought--
是吗？芭芭拉·史翠珊已经要求E频道（E Network）的八卦节目不要再叫她“Babs”了。没错，她不想再被称为“Babs”了。是的。唯一的问题是现在他们开始叫她“Poopyhead”（屎头）了。我想……
Andy Richter is the co-host of Late Night with Conan O'Brien . He sat on stage ad-libbing through the whole memorable, nearly out of control hour. And he says this about poopyhead.
安迪·里希特（Andy Richter）是《柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀》的联合主持人。他在整个难忘的、近乎失控的小时节目中坐在舞台上即兴发挥。他说起关于“Poopyhead”的这件事。
When we're planning, we're ordering jokes, putting them in order or little bits of comedy for a sketch. And there will be one that will feature the word "dumbass" or "boobs." And we'll say, yeah, people will laugh at that word. So doing it with children is just a little easier. And it's less censorable.
当我们计划时，我们会按顺序排列笑话，或者是短小的喜剧片段。其中会有使用“dumbass”（傻瓜）或“boobs”（乳房）之类词汇的。我们会说，是的，人们会因为那个词发笑。所以和孩子们一起做这一点稍微容易一些。而且受审查的可能性也较小。
Now Andy, we're putting this interview that I'm doing with you into an episode of our program about people battling natural forces beyond their control. And one thing that I think made this particular hour of television that you guys did such amazing TV is that-- watching it anyway-- I always had the sense that the entire thing felt like, at any moment, it could tumble out of control. And I wonder, is that the way it felt on stage?
那么安迪，我们正把我对你的这段采访放进我们关于人们与失控的自然力量抗争的节目中。我认为你们做的这个特别小时节目成为如此令人惊叹的电视的一个原因是——至少看着是这样——我总觉得整个事情就像随时可能失去控制。我想知道，舞台上感觉是这样吗？
Probably worse. It probably felt worse. Well, one mistake we made is we had what we called the boredom monster, which was a noise. And we'd say, uh-oh, the boredom monster is coming. And then we'd cut away to tape of this big monster that we created coming down a darkly lit hallway, moving slowly.
可能更糟。感觉可能更糟。嗯，我们犯的一个错误是，我们设置了所谓的“无聊怪物”（boredom monster），那是一种噪音。我们会说，哦不，无聊怪物来了。然后我们切换到我们制作的这个大怪物的录像，它缓慢地走下阴暗的走廊。
He's right outside the studio. Come on. [MONSTER SOUNDS]
它就在演播室外面。快点。[怪物声]
And they had to scream and applaud to get the monster to go away and not come in and get us, which we thought, well, the kids will be frightened of the monster. And so that will pimp them into screaming and applauding, which is just another applause light gimmick. What we didn't realize is that the kids wanted the money shot. They wanted to see that monster. They wanted it to come in.
他们必须尖叫和鼓掌让怪物走开，不要进来抓我们，我们以为，嗯，孩子们会害怕怪物的。所以这会驱使他们尖叫和鼓掌，这只是另一个灯光提示的噱头。我们没意识到的是，孩子们想要看到“金镜头”（money shot）。他们想看那个怪物。他们想让它进来。
So they wouldn't scream?
所以他们不尖叫？
Well, they would scream, but we had introduced the word "boring" to their lexicon. So after the monster didn't come in, they cheered because they wanted to help by cheering, and that's what they'd been asked to do.
嗯，他们会尖叫，但我们把“无聊”这个词引入了他们的词汇库。所以当怪物没有进来时，他们欢呼，因为他们想通过欢呼来帮忙，而那是要求他们做的事。
To keep the monster from coming in.
不让怪物进来。
Yeah, but then when it didn't come in, they were mad. And they started chanting, "Boring, boring."
是的，但当它没有进来时，他们很生气。他们开始高呼：“无聊，无聊。”
And on stage, what are you thinking at that point?
在舞台上，那时你在想什么？
Well, I was seriously thinking of just doing a large pratfall just to change the mood.
嗯，我真的在考虑做一个大动作的跌倒来改变心情。
Right, I will do anything I can.
对，我愿意做任何我能做的事。
Yes, exactly. I'll pull down my pants and dance around. And especially when it's with children, you think, what do they like? If they had allowed me to defecate, I probably would have.
是的，没错。我会脱下裤子跳舞。尤其是和孩子们在一起时，你会想，他们喜欢什么？如果他们允许我排便，我可能真会那么做。
There's a point where you guys have Dave Foley come out. And I timed this. It's 29 seconds before it erupts into complete chaos. Let me play this for you.
有一个点你们让戴夫·弗利（Dave Foley）出来。我计算过。离完全爆发混乱还有29秒。让我放给你听。
Oh man, welcome to the show.
天哪，欢迎来到节目。
Oh, why thank you Conan. Hi.
哦，谢谢柯南。嗨。
Oh, I should say, that's Dave Foley of News Radio.
哦，我应该说，那是《新闻广播台》（News Radio）的戴夫·弗利。
Hi, kids.
嗨，孩子们。
Isn't this nice? Everyone go, hi, Dave.
这不挺好吗？大家说，嗨，戴夫。
Hi, Dave.
嗨，戴夫。
Hi.
嗨。
It's nice, isn't it? It's a nice change of pace.
挺好的，不是吗？这是一个不错的节奏变化。
Yeah, it is. Well, for you. You don't have kids.
是的，是挺好。嗯，对你来说。你没孩子。
No. You have them. So this is sheer hell for you, isn't it?
没有。你有。所以这对你来说简直是人间地狱，对吧？
It's just like being home, because I have, actually, 150 children.
就像在家里一样，因为我实际上有150个孩子。
All right. Hey kids, settle down. We're going to talk to Dave Foley for a bit. It's not going to take very long.
好吧。嘿孩子们，安静下来。我们要和戴夫·弗利谈一会儿。不会花太长时间的。
No.
不。
Right?
对吧？
Boring.
无聊。
Kids. Dave?
孩子们。戴夫？
Yes?
什么？
I understand you did some traveling lately.
我听说你最近去旅行了。
I did. I went to Africa. I flew to Zimbabwe, Africa, and flew into Harare. And then from there, went on to spend Christmas--
是的。我去了非洲。我飞到了津巴布韦，非洲，飞进了哈拉雷。然后从那里继续去过圣诞节——
I mean did you anticipate that it was going to fall apart that fast?
我是说你有没有预料到它会崩塌得那么快？
No, no. And I felt terrible for Dave. He just-- it's humiliating. As much rationalizations as you can do and say, well, they're just children and they don't really know who I am. Still, you've got about 700 human beings screaming at you, "Boring" when you're a performer. So it's your job to be interesting. So I felt terrible.
没有，没有。我为戴夫感到难过。他只是——这很屈辱。无论你如何合理化并说，嗯，他们只是孩子，他们不认识我是谁。但这仍然让你面对700个在你表演时尖叫着“无聊”的人类。所以保持有趣是你的工作。所以我感觉糟透了。
And actually, I think there was an edit taken out of there, where I think Conan got, actually, a little more shrill with the children. But we took it out.
而且实际上，我认为那里被剪掉了一段，我觉得柯南实际上对孩子们变得更尖锐了。但我们剪掉了。
Why? What did he do? What did he say?
为什么？他做了什么？他说了什么？
He just said, hey, come on, quiet down. Something like that.
他只是说，嘿，快点，安静点。之类的。
I just thought it was a really tough performance moment for Conan. It just seemed like he had entered into this territory where he had no idea what would be the right thing and the wrong thing. There were no guides. There's no experience to back him up.
我只是觉得这对柯南来说是一个非常艰难的表演时刻。他似乎进入了这个领域，他完全不知道什么是正确的做法，什么是错误的做法。没有向导。没有经验支持他。
No, the only experience in that instance would be grade school teacher or parenthood.
不，那种情况下唯一的经验就是小学老师或为人父母。
I have to say, this is the most interesting hour of TV I've seen in I don't know how long.
我必须说，这是我见过的最有趣的电视节目，不知道多久了。
Well, thank you.
嗯，谢谢你。
Did you guys view it as a success?
你们把它看作成功了吗？
I don't think so. It was so hard to think of it as anything but a train wreck, just because it felt so uncomfortable and felt so draining. I think that afterwards, we just breathed such a sigh of relief and felt so exhausted that it was hard to believe that it was good.
我不这么认为。很难把它看作除了列车失事以外的任何东西，仅仅因为它感觉太不舒服，感觉太耗竭了。我想事后，我们只是松了一口气，感到太精疲力竭了，以至于很难相信它是好的。
See that's the thing, you were in the grip of a force more powerful than you were.
看，这就是重点，你被一种比你更强大的力量所掌控。
Absolutely.
绝对如此。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder, senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell.
好了，我们的节目今天由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和我自己制作，还有南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder），高级编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough），特约编辑杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin），顾问萨拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this program, call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买本节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱地址，[email protected]。本节目由公共广播国际台（Public Radio International）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际台。